en novembre 2021 Jean-Luc Lahaye mise en
examen est placé en détention provisoire
le chanteur de 68 ans est accusé de
viols et d'agressions sexuelle sur
mineur de plus de 15 ans libéré quelques
mois plus tard et on retrait depuis
cette condamnation le chanteur star des
années 80 vient pourtant d'annoncer son
retour sur scène pour fêter son
anniversaire
c'est ici que nous avons rendez-vous le
23 décembre pour un showcase un concert
un retour qui a fait bondir deux de ses
victimes présumées je suis heurté que la
programmation de ces nouvelles dates
soient autant banalisée vraiment je
trouve ça extrêmement choquant dans la
tourmente après la programmation d'un
concert le producteur de Jean-Luc Lahaye
exprime pour TPMP
alors il est 20h11 on est en direct
ma mère t'adore Daniel ah déjà je fais
un pas
bouge dans la gueule
est-ce que pour vous Jean-Luc Lahaye
doit remonter sur scène ou pas Gilles
Verdez oui ah c'est quoi la question
exactement
depuis le 5 octobre depuis 5 novembre
2021 pardon mais le 24 mai il est sorti
de prison sous contrôle judiciaire mais
une question bordel oui et si les
sorties sont contrôle judiciaire c'est
pour une bonne raison que l'on va vous
révéler ce soir voilà on va vous révéler
ce soir pourquoi il est sous contrôle
judiciaire et donc il est libre et son
contrôle judiciaire ne lui impose pas
l'interdiction de chanter impose pas
l'interdiction de rencontrer des gens
c'est un contrôle judiciaire dont on
peut discuter mais voyez vous l'avez
derrière vous demeurer à Paris pointer
verser une caution ne pas entrer en
contact avec les protagonistes du
dossier même même et on peut en discuter
aussi ça peut être jugé scandale le même
le fait de rencontrer des mineurs ne lui
est pas
interdits
de mon point de vue les présumés
innocent c'est sans doute contestable
mais il a le droit de remonter sur scène
voilà voilà et on s'en fout qu'il est le
droit il y a un moment donné est-ce
qu'on peut avoir un peu de bon sens et
de morale dans le pays on parle tout le
temps des des lois des règles des trucs
qu'est-ce qu'on a le droit est-ce qu'on
a pas le droit non on s'en fout le gars
il faut avoir un peu de bon sens et de
morale c'est à dire que là c'est à
partir du moment où il y a deux victimes
qui sont en train de te dire que ça les
blesse et qu'elle trouve ça
insurmontable et bah il monte pas sur
scène et point barre en fait il y a le
producteur qui a répondu je suis très
surpris par la réaction de ces deux
femmes qui à me tous les médias elle
serait choquée que Jean-Luc remonte sur
scène mais il n'a absolument pas jugé
coupable et encore moins condamné il est
toujours présumé innocent tout comme
elle sont toujours des présumés victimes
et c'est vrai que là là dessus Gilles
Verdez suis la justice
monsieur Montiel non il remonte sur
scène également pour son association
sans famille très belle association il
est vrai aussi
ça n'excuse rien du tout soyons clair
rien du tout ça fait 30 ans
l'association sans famille c'est une
association formidable
il faut pas se substituer tout le temps
la justice exactement on a un tribunal
médiatique alors c'est facile
c'est affreux ces histoires elles sont
terribles ces histoires non mais là où
il y a une justice quand même qui s'est
prononcé pour le moment donc il peut
chanter
parce que moi je suis contre le fait
qu'il remonte sur scène là je rejoins
pas d'abord Gilles c'est
qu'effectivement il y a un contrôle qui
fait que les mineurs c'est Roland Perez
qui dansait pas longtemps les mineurs ne
pourront pas il pourra pas faire de
monter de mineurs sur scène pendant
qu'il chante et nous pourrons pas non
plus dans sa loge donc déjà
effectivement
il avait il est mis en examen pour de
des histoires de viol sur mineur je suis
d'accord qui n'a pas été condamné mais
il a été condamné il y a quelques années
sur des personnes différentes mais pour
des mêmes raisons où il a été condamné
c'est là où c'est extrêmement choquant
c'est qu'effectivement il a été déjà
condamné pas sur ces filles-là mais pour
les mêmes raisons je le répète il y a
quelques années donc là oui ça me choque
qui remonte sur scène alors que même si
pour ces deux personnes là il est
toujours mis examen et pas condamné en
revanche dans le passé il a été condamné
pour ses raisons-là là effectivement ça
me choque je ne comprends même pas si
moi donc et après l'étude approfondie du
dossier c'est la justice qui a bien fait
son travail d'investigation qui a
finalement remis en liberté Jean-Luc
Lahaye ce n'est pas on lit online c'est
Olivier Uzon producteur de Jean-Luc
Lahaye qui a dit ça Gilbert oui alors
juste deux choses il faut préciser
Mathieu que Jean-Luc Lahaye je donne
simplement sa version il nie il explique
que ça sur des rapports consentis et que
pour lui il y a vengeance ou recherche
de profit financiers de la part des
plaignants juste ça et maintenant je
vais vous dire pourquoi il a été libéré
ça ça t'intéressant on a un mail qui a
été envoyé par l'une des plaignantes à
Jean-Luc Lahay c'est une série de mails
envoyés entre 2015 et 2020 et quand le
juge d'applications des peines voilà
jamais il est derrière vous le [ __ ] je
meurs remémore tes gestes ta voix et
c'est signé le mail alors voilà
je puisse 116 dans ce passé que nous
avons en commun rien n'est plus beau je
m'ennuie de toi je veux ton regard posé
sur moi toute tes manifestations
devenues synonymes de bonheur mais tu
n'es pas là et je suis impuissant alors
je m'encourage jour et nuit en
anticipant le moment où nous serons à
nouveau réunis et plus fort qu'avant
alors c'est une banalité
laissez-le juste pour me dire merci on
n'est pas là pour juger le mail il y a
une série de mails envoyés comme celui
entre 2015 et 2020 alors on peut me dire
elles étaient sous influence manipules
très bien mais néanmoins néanmoins nous
ne sommes pas des justiciers le juge
d'application des peines lui a évalué
ses mails en disant que ça affaiblissait
quand même les accusations
le 24 mai il est sorti de prison voilà
on peut en discuter mais c'est le jus
d'application sur la voie de supplément
à estimer qu'il pouvait être placé sous
contrôle judiciaire le fait qu'il soit
en liberté ne choque pas ces deux femmes
mais uniquement le fait qu'il puisse
remonter sur scène qu'il puisse célébrer
son anniversaire et qu'il fasse plaisir
au milieu de fans qui l'attendent avec
impatience Olivier Uzon le producteur du
spectacle il a également dit only online
donc c'est la production alors organiser
plusieurs choses avec Jean-Luc et depuis
nous sommes en étroite relation avec son
fan club toutes les femmes qui le
connaissent et qui le suivent depuis ses
débuts la précis et le considère en plus
de l'artiste qu'il est comme un homme
exceptionnel de gentillesse de
bienveillance et d'humanité il continue
de dénoncer en évoquant l'acharnement
médiatique dont Jean-Luc Lahaye serait
victime cet acharnement médiatique à son
encontre et pitoyable il ne sert qu'à
faire de l'audience et tenter de
détruire sa carrière la chanson c'est
son métier depuis plus de 40 ans il a
besoin de revenir sur scène de créer de
chanter et de s'exprimer c'est s'agit
oui c'est absolument ça donc il justifie
ce concert donc à l'Européen le 23
décembre on peut en discuter mais au nom
de quoi au nom de quoi doit-il
aujourd'hui alors qu'il n'est pas
condamné présumé innocent Mathieu sur
cette affaire au nom quoi au nom des
condamnations similaires par le passé
pour les mêmes raisons c'est en ça
Gilles oui que je dis que c'est remis en
liberté
bien sûr le droit le public jugera moi
j'espère que les centres vides mais le
public
il y a plein de messages avec Bernard
beaucoup de monde il y a beaucoup de
gens exactement
non parce que là il est il est remis en
liberté est-ce qu'il faut aller donc
contre la justice et dire il n'a pas le
droit Gilles c'est ça en fait la
question exactement la question c'est
qu'il n'a pas été condamné présumé
innocent doit-on le priver de son métier
doit-on faire un paria c'est toute une
question et subtile et sensible mais de
mon point de vue de mon point de vue il
a le droit à ce concert des 70 ans
l'un de nous et accusée de choses
terribles voilà on est remis en liberté
on est chroniqueurs on n'est pas du tout
sans problème non mais non si vous êtes
remis en liberté que la justice a dit
que vous n'étiez pas coupable
si vous avez perdu votre peine vous
revenez
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous nous
pour les mêmes les mêmes postes ça
dépend des accusations
non plus voilà non mais après ça dépend
bien sûr
chroniqueurs mais vous par exemple si
demain vous avez volé des lunettes euh
mais c'est vrai voilà où Mathieu voilà
avec des mineurs
pour nous reprendre bien sûr la fin du
procès
alors c'est vrai
Mathieu mais toi et Benjamin parfois
vous nous dites vous me dites vous êtes
un justicier Bernard médiatique là la
présomption d'innocence excusez-moi mais
sur cette affaire vous la foulez au pied
non et Kelly
je te parle pas de ce truc actuel je te
parle de ce qu'il a fait avant ah pour
lesquelles il a été condamné alors on
est condamné on a purgé sa peine alors
plus 2e chaleur
un exemple
l'un de nous l'un de nous fait une
horreur sur un mineur voilà d'accord
franchement il est condamné l'un de nous
fait je sais pas deux ans de prison on
revient dans TPMP on refait une erreur
sur un mineur mais là pour le moment
l'enquête est en cours on sait pas si on
a condamné ou pas
on revient sur l'émission
moi la moindre connerie vous ferez je
m'en servirai pour vous
emmerdez
ce serait une chance pour moi voilà me
dire voilà tu peux m'en débarrasser
voilà c'est important de comprendre
qu'il est présumé de ça pour le moment
mais que nous ce qu'on dit c'est qu'il a
été condamné par le passé pour des
fesses similaires il a pas excuse-moi il
n'a pas été condamné pour viol agression
sexuelle pour la aux gens pourquoi il
était condamné et pourquoi il a il est
mis en examen s'il te plaît alors là il
est mis en examen pour viol c'est grave
agression sexuelle plus de 15 ans et
corruption de mineur donc les les
risques une très lourde peine et alors
là où c'est très compliqué c'est que ce
sont deux jeunes femmes qui avaient déjà
porté plainte contre lui qui après avait
retiré leur plainte qu'on portait plein
de nouveaux contre lui donc voilà donc
Mathieu il y a des éléments sérieux mais
il y a aussi des éléments dans cette
affaire ou je vous le rappelle une mère
des deux plaignantes et elle-même mise
en examen pour non dénoncer d'accord
elle est elle-même mise en examen on a
soupçonné que ce soit les maires qui
entre guillemets approche
instrumentaliste merci Géraldine leur
leur fille et les approches de Jean-Luc
Lahay donc c'est une affaire extrêmement
complexe ce que je dis simplement en
ayant des éléments du dossier ce qu'on
peut avoir c'est que on ne peut pas le
juger avant le procès là c'est
impossible là on ne peut dire pour
connaître par le passé évidemment on
parle du passé par le passé il avait été
condamné plusieurs fois une fois pour
atteindre sexuelle sur mineur une fois
pour corruption mineure c'est pas rien
non plus quand même ce que tu dis qu'il
n'est pas accusé pour les mêmes choses
c'est par exemple il y a pas violent
d'accord je disais ça mais n'oublions
pas le passé quand même oui je sais je
sais mais pour l'instant il est présumé
innocent de quelque chose pour
lesquelles il a déjà été condamné je
sais que le passé c'est le passé
techniquement les arguments de Gilles
sont juste mais moi ce qui m'énerve dans
ces affaires de mort c'est que souvent
on se cache derrière les mots pour faire
passer les accusés pour des innocents
complets moi ce que j'ai reçu donc j'ai
envie quand même c'est qu'on se justifie
sur les accusations parce qu'on parle de
de présomption d'innocence de
prescription mais concrètement sur
l'effet reproché est-ce que c'est vrai
ou pas est-ce que c'est vrai par exemple
que les mamans ont filmé les actes on a
parlé de ça on a envie de connaître la
vérité et je sais pas si les gens
aujourd'hui ont envie d'applaudir
quelqu'un qui est accusé de ses faits là
qui sont quand même extrêmement graves
merci merci
non à 76%